it was a disastrous weekend for the
cuomo's
the q-tip brothers can't stop
embarrassing themselves
andrew's clinging to power and facing
growing calls to resign
after two more accusers came forward
almost
50 state lawmakers including top
democrats now want them to step aside
and new york state republicans just
announced an impeachment resolution
but the governor says he's not going
anywhere
i was elected by the people of the state
i wasn't elected by politicians
uh i'm not going to resign because of
allegations
uh the premise of resigning because of
allegations
is actually anti-democratic no there is
no way i resign
now you'd think with all the
controversies swirling around andrew
cuomo his brother chris
would do everything to stay out of
trouble instead he did this
just looking out of the window
watching the asphalt grow
thinking how it all looks how do you
know the words
the good times you know i'm black on the
inside good times
[Music]
all right i'm not going to knock him for
that it's just a joke it's just ironic
that
the fake racial outrage machine that cnn
created
is now boomeranging on that comment all
right juan what do you think about the
cuomo brothers and their weekend
well i'm glad you agree with me you know
across racial lines we just think that
was a joke they were just having fun
i think the more serious issue is the
governor's future here jesse
and i think he's in trouble i think he's
trying to buy time
uh he's hanging on by his fingernails if
this was a boxing match he'd be holding
the other boxer and trying just to slow
things down
you know the a attorney general's
investigation
and she's named some people today to
that panel
that investigation is going to buy him
some time
but you know my sense is we're watching
the final act here i i don't see
you know i don't know how it ends i
don't know when it
ends but i think it's gonna end right
and
and uh my sense is that you know if
more women keep coming forward uh i
don't know how he hangs on there now let
me just say
as a caveat to you know my thinking on
this
that you know it could be that
he just doesn't run for another term
that he announces shortly
that you know what i'm not running for a
fourth term
and that that satisfies that that acts
as a pressure release
valve and a lot of people say well you
know what let's just move on
i don't know but i do know i saw a
quinnipiac poll over the weekend
you know done after both the nursing
home scandal and the
harassment scandal had broken and still
most new yorkers don't want him to
resign it's overwhelmingly partisan but
overwhelming but it's clear
most of they don't want him to resign
but they also don't want him to run
again
next year greg i could see him just
locking himself down and and and
not resigning at all and just trying to
weather the storm couldn't you
well i'm i don't know call me
old-fashioned but i still believe the
rest home massacre
is worse than the harassment stuff so i
don't of course you know
uh and and i'm wondering with all of
these these women are going to keep
coming forward and
as the number of accusers grow will his
staff
suddenly decide to play that number down
too it's like oh no those were different
because they happened in a hospital
maybe they'll do that as for uh cc and
the muscle factory
i'm gonna be like you guys i'm gonna cut
chris
slack on this even though i know that
their side would never do the same for
us and i do think that like when you
think about
like what is what is really being said
out there that's horrible
how is joy reid not getting not getting
any attention for the horrible things
she's saying saying republicans would
pay higher taxes
so they could say the n word which she
says that
you have to understand she's talking
about white people so she's racist
she's smearing an entire group of people
but because it's on msnbc
she can say it so we're folk like yeah
cuomo is without
chris cuomo without question he's the
michael scott of cable news right
you know he looks at the fun he thinks
he's funnier and more charming that he
is and so he makes these silly mistakes
and we all laugh because it's human
but meanwhile there's somebody spewing
vile hate
on msnbc every day but
immunity yeah and comcast seems to be
okay with that yeah all right dagon
mcdowell
um your prediction does does he just
so stubborn andrew cuomo dig in and
and not go anywhere and even try to run
again
he won't try to run again but he is such
a megalomaniac that he will believe that
he's impervious
yeah but he is buffalo bill without the
dance moves
he had a hand in killing 15 000 elderly
new yorkers
and then lied about it and covered it up
i think his downfall will be
if and when federal prosecutors in the
justice department
start talking to those aides who covered
up
the nursing home deaths that happened in
hospitals
once they start interviewing them
because a lot of the federal government
that's a crime i think that that might
be the tipping point for him
but cuomo the cuomo bros get re get
get away with everything because they
were born and raised in power and
privilege they get away with it
because of their daddy and because their
politics are on the right side
meaning the left side chris cuomo don't
forget
last year nothing happened to him wasn't
canceled when he said please show me
where it says that protests are supposed
to be polite and peaceful
and then people died and were injured
and people lost their
livelihoods all summer long that is the
untouchable nature it's why he
interviewed his
governor brother and and basically never
asked about the nursing home deaths
for months yeah actually doesn't it say
that they have to be peaceful in the
constitution
all right dana perino remember governor
ralph
northam oh i think the entire world told
him he had to resign
and he didn't look it's my talking point
it's perfect
we didn't even coordinate no like he so
he just grinded
he just decided i'm gonna grind it out i
was like he'll just put his head down he
just worked and everyone thought he
would have to resign but remember it
wasn't sexual harassment
okay like apparently that's different
um and you keep hearing people saying if
one more woman comes out
then he'll have to resign well now
there's multiple and that's still not
happening
i do ask this jessie where
is the vice president on this
and i i wonder at some point like does
she want to say something
but is being asked not to or is she not
saying something that would be
to me seemingly against her principles
um and at some point does she decide to
say
look this she was going to want to say
something she's going to do an interview
she's going to be asked
and the other thing is like with her i
think at some point
both biden and kamala harris might come
to a decision
that someone needs to call andrew cuomo
and say this is a distraction that we
don't need
and at the very least as once and other
people have said he'll just announce
that he's not going to run for another
term
all right all good points except
gutfeltz
coming up